la sorte
ajouté
la mise en valeur du patrimoine et du
soutien à la création
170 millions d'euros apportés par l'état
en investissement sur un programme de
550 millions de francs soit un
investissement représentant là encore
1500 années de travail ce qui équivaut à
400 personnes durant quatre ans ce
programme ambitieux
permettra de doter la ville de toulouse
d'une panoplie complète
d'équipements culturels dignes d'une
grande capitale régionale à vocation
européenne
désormais apprenait cette charte
culturelle
les investissements de la ville de
toulouse et de l'état porte davantage
sur les arts vivants
sur le spectacle par exemple sur la
musique que sur le patrimoine et c'est
donc une évolution susceptible de
développer encore plus l'influencent de
cluj et son rayonnement dans l'ensemble
de la région un rayonnement qui passera
avant tout par la poursuite des travaux
de restauration engagée en 88 le musée
d'art contemporain aux abattoirs devrait
voir le jour en 96 et la fondation inard
être reconvertis visite trois en
quantité de l'espace côté nouveautés
place au théâtre et à la musique avec la
création d'un centre d'art dramatique et
donner du thorium à saint pierre des
cuisines soutient également aux
compagnies de danses régionales sans
oublier le septième art la seconde
cinémathèque de france se voit offrir de
nouveaux locaux de travail et de
conservation